human nature takes over
and doesn't matter how much you absolutely feel like you're in love
and this is gonna work forever
human nature is a thing
and humans grow
evolve and change
and that's that is the only certain thing that we know
I am right now a single mother to four kids
I'm 41 years old
and I was married for 10 years and
um realized that
that traditional gender life is miserable and lonely and sad
and
I was convinced that if I just found the right words to explain to my husband
the man who watched me birth four of his children unmedicated
saw me struggle through the adapting and changing of becoming a mother
I was so positive that if I just found the right words
the right combination
the right moment to say this perfect combination of words
he would finally get it
he would wake up and he would see
oh
I don't I'm so
I didn't realize that this is what
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
all the previous conversations that we've had
the 10 years you've been explaining these things to me
and how they've only gotten worse
I've never really improved any of these things you've been asking me to do
babe I'm
I'm never again
from today on
I'm your husband
I'm your faithful husband like I promised you that day
but that's not reality
he does know he does know
he's an adult
if he is an adult functioning in this world
he's got jobs
he's got other relationships that he's able to maintain
he can go to the grocery store and come home without
you know dying or getting arrested
he's a fully functioning adult that absolutely understands the pain he's causing
but he also understands that you are beholden to those marriage vows
not him he knows that you hold to those marriage vows tightly
that you are bound by them
but clearly he's not
so if you're staying in a marriage because it's been any length of time
number one that's the sunk cost fallacy
you're just staying because there's been a long time
but it's never gonna change
and he is never gonna wake up
because he already is awake
and he is manipulating the situation for his benefit
and he will continue to do so as long as you allow it